[Applause]
that's funny new people look at you look
at you clap for yourself you animals
happy Friday and as always on a Friday
the thing we do first we welcome
tonight's guests
that music her smile so big she uses a
Swiffer for a toothbrush
former Fox News anchor Patty Ann Brown
oh look at that huh when he flies he
never complains about leg room this
contributor
yes she is to put rocks in her pockets
on Windy days Fox News contributor cat
too
and finally his shoe size is Escalade my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus foreign
before we get to some news stories you
know what it's time for
yeah Greg's leftovers
oh man yeah it's leftovers
where I read the jokes we didn't use
this week and as always it's my first
time reading these so I'm very nervous
here we go a recent AP poll reveals that
a majority of Democrats would not
support a 2024 Biden presidential
campaign in response Joe said if he does
run in 2024 he promised it'll be a great
first term
struggling retailer Bed Bath and Beyond
recently avoided a bankruptcy filing
after an injection of 225 million in
funds unfortunately that shrinks to 180
million once creditors use their 20 off
coupons
are murder man
that's a lot a San Francisco city
supervisor suggested legalizing
prostitution following complaints that
it's taken over high traffic areas if
the measure passes hookers can go about
their business as long as it's in the
back of a Prius
[Laughter]
before the State of the Union on Tuesday
Mitt Romney went after Congressman
George Santos berating him for lying on
his resume Santos responded by accusing
Romney of fibbing on his resume where he
says
Republican
a new interview Armie Hammer that's the
actor his extreme estranged wife
Elizabeth Chambers claimed he broke her
heart in nine million pieces to his
credit though he did eat all of them
she's claims to like cannibalism
I know Patty Anne wasn't aware of that
following His official retirement from
the NFL Tom Brady stripped down to take
an underwear selfie
when asked if it was a thirst trap
intended for ex-wife to sell he replied
no only fans
[Laughter]
see because it's a double entender
pop star Sam Smith made headlines this
week after a satanic themed performance
at the Grammys
the performance had many industry
experts wondering if he sold his soul
for some pancakes
that's just bad
actually Sam is non-binary which means
nutritionists were really ahead of the
curve when they warned us to look out
for those damn trans fats
oh boy
truly a leftover
Arnold Schwarzenegger was reportedly
involved in a car accident Sunday
morning after a woman riding a bike
swerved it to his Lane everyone is fine
which is good because last time Arnold
hit a woman he barely knew from behind
this happened
laughs
that's good
you leave Arnold alone yes he's my hero
pictures of Ben Affleck's miserable
facial expressions while he was at the
Grammys Sunday night have gone viral the
last time Ben looked out and happy he
was at a screening of all of his movies
finally a sleeping commuter on a New
York City subway awaken to find a large
rat crawling all over his body
yeah it was such a disturbing site
several of his fellow passengers
actually stopped having sex
yeah let's do some news okay but first
we're letting you choose what we're
going to cover it's time for
[Music]
the the drill I give you two topics and
whichever gets the most Applause wins
it's the same way Lou Dobbs would win
wet t-shirt contests
you know
in the week ending February 4th the
advanced figure for unemployment claims
was 196 thousand an increase of 13 000
from the previous week's unrevised level
of 183 thousands it's a slight uptick
but what does this mean for our economy
going forward okay let's hear your
applause
wow that sucks
Tyrus applauded all right here's the
second uh story
the Canadian teacher with giant fake
breasts
filthy filthy people
well big boobs wins again
hit it
if it happens up there we report down
here you're watching gazumba gate Canada
21.
it's almost half a year you remember her
the teachers whose boobs are so big
you'll need a sherpa to climb them
well she's back a brand new photo was
taken of her inside the high school
where she teaches students how to work
with wood
now around her wood definitely doesn't
mean they're aroused but speaking of
wood she's hobbling Along on a pair of
crutches with an unknown injury however
she falls over I'm confident she'll
bounce right back
and when students saw those Shadows that
meant six more weeks of nipples the size
of doorknobs
talk about the School of Hard knockers
to beef up this segment here's some more
trans news from our neighbors to the
North Western University in Ontario is
reportedly installing 150 machines
inside men's bathrooms that will
dispense tampons
it's part of an initiative to support
quote students who menstruate
I know didn't there used to be a name
for people who did that
we'll have to check with my gynecologist
PAB you're a woman
allegedly yes yes
did you ever think you'd live in a time
where men menstruate
yeah uh the whole thing is crazy and you
know my question really though is why do
these college students feel regardless
of which bathroom you put them in that
they're entitled to free menstrual
products to begin with you know the
problem is the is the philanthropy yeah
any other things but the the university
Western University put out a statement
saying menstrual products are not a
luxury they are a necessity
period yes
literally
but you know a lot of things are
Necessities they all need clothing they
need toilet paper is everyone supposed
to provide these things for them for
free and and it's and then to ones who
are delusional who one who people who
claim they're men but have periods this
is crazy okay so Joey Johnny Joey
whatever your name is today I don't know
if you look at these two stories
effectively what you're seeing is a
we're see looking at a culture that's
paralyzed uh by fear of being ostracized
so we're seeing a delusion take place
but nobody can pop that balloon so to
speak you know if someone who is a huge
fan of giant and Prosthetics yes
really didn't think somebody kept that
up for me yeah
um yeah
I I don't get it I think that um if you
go through the surgery and that's just
the size of what you came out with
that's one thing right but when you're
just strapping it on in the morning with
the wig like that's still a dude and he
doesn't get to wear them to school right
like my kid can't wear anything to
school like they let him wear pajamas to
school which is ridiculous you wear
sweatpants to school but now they've got
teachers wearing just giant prosthetic
to school I don't get it man no it it's
the thing is he is a fetishist yes he's
not a woman this perversion yeah or he
is pulling off like I say cat the
greatest prank ever it's now 21 weeks
he's been keeping true to form I mean
he's not breaking character at all even
when he's skydived and his wig fell off
he is gorgeous though let's be honest I
mean eat your heart out Sam Smith
or Army Hammer
[Laughter]
cat
oh what's wrong no I just I said last
time we talked about this would somebody
from Canada please reach out to me and
give me any inside information so I have
something more to add because it's it's
like basically we're talking about this
again because there's a photo with
crutches right like that that's I need
more I need Canada I need your help and
honestly I did not bring this up last
time but I am going to go there this
time and say you guys owe me because
people like me have contributed a lot to
your economy yeah so what about tampons
no no people I'm serious what because uh
people like me who were 19 years old
living anywhere around the Detroit area
spent a lot of money getting drunk
legally in Windsor oh I had no idea okay
and it wasn't always easy the next
morning when you wake up in that hotel
room with five of your friends okay yes
but I did it Canada for your economy and
you need to reach out and help me
because next every time there's a
mention of the boob teacher we're
talking about the boob teacher again uh
tampons I don't I'm Pro tampons like I
don't know like you know what's more
expensive than a tampon not having a
tampon
that is true think about it
yeah in your face tampon haters all
right here you know Tyrus how there was
like if you look back in the past they
have names for eras like the
enlightenment the Dark Ages isn't this
like the delusional era like we're not
allowed to poke this poke the hole in
this thing no it's the dumbass era and
are you entertained yeah no no you you
voted for this
are you entertained you've got what you
wanted are you not entertained
I'm with cat on this one there's just so
no as as president would say they are
there with this here you know but here's
the thing ladies you thought the fellas
took too long in the bathroom now yeah
where do you see us come out with
tampons in her nose and be like look how
absorbent these things are these are
amazing oh there's so many things I
could use them for it's going to lead to
more arguments more problems one thing
for fellas though
why is there a tampon in your truck oh I
was in the bathroom last night and I
grabbed one by accident darling so I
mean you got that going for you yeah
with right next to the breath mix and
the dental dam yes it's true though it's
like if you think about it they run out
of toilet paper or a tampon it's like a
super absorbent roll of toilet paper
yeah it like I said I had a bloody nose
once yeah and my mom thinking fast was
like here and I was like no this is
perfect it absorbed everything
it has a little
space
no idea
that my mom
gave me a tampon to stick in my nose but
hey bloody nose was gone there you go I
think we're absorbent I felt very fresh
this is a quite an instructional show I
have to say hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else